Ok, let's try this out!
So method two
And Otto's going to carry the wheelbarrow
Of course we have to take an around the net!
Almost a roller
Many gardeners and constructions workers
would be impressed by this
Vote your favourite around the net in the comments
Maybe Miikka you should
hop in
That looks comfortable
Don't you trust me?
I don't trust the wheelbarrow
Got this one?
Yeah I got it
Finish him!
Nice work
We're gonna turn me into a...
Table tennis boxer
Yeah
My left punch wasn't as...
Okay
Come on!
Emil, you gotta catch up!
That didn't really...
Work as we thought
A very unsuccessful boxing practice
The next challenge
is to make a hole in the racket
I think that's it
That looks like a hole to me
Ok let's play then
Did it go through the hole?
Yeah it did
It's so frustrating because you know
The shot would normally go on
I was trying to hit it
Double fake shot
Ok let's make a bigger hole into the racket
There's more hole than there is racket
I can hit a good side spin with this
That was really big topspin!
It is actually quite hard
Cameraman Jackpot
It's not a lot of fun to play with this but
It's a cool and nice idea
Clear!
Don't forget to hit subscribe
And watch our previous videos there
Until next time!